ladies and gentlemen it's the busiest
man in quarantine
Josh can most tired man look at these
bags right there there's like these are
shopping bags now Josh that's because
you've been like changing the
entertainment industry bit by bit for
the last ten weeks have you slept by the
way not nearly enough not nearly enough
I I'm definitely tired I'm feeling it's
also just gloomy gray skies out today
which i think is part of it but that but
you know always exciting to talk to you
and to talk about things that I'm really
excited about like like artemus which
which you know at a time everyone can
use just a momentary break of chaos and
hardship and pain I hope we continue to
bring light and and and escapism where
we can to to families need it I
definitely had to do a double take when
I was watching oh wait is that that's
just that's just me do you have your
kids seen it yet and what did they think
when they saw you my kids haven't seen
the film but they I would FaceTime then
twice a day from 7:00 and then when they
came to visit me obviously brought them
through he said to come see me and I
mean it just never cease to amaze them
and they were so tickled by such a hairy
daddy yes
arey Dada how many projects have you've
done during quarantine are you keeping
track my lobster and lobster oh you're
getting trying to do during quarantine
though I'm just trying to do everything
that I can yeah to bring joy and and and
make a difference if I thought I've read
about it apart you know I it's it's been
a very obviously a very tough week plus
here and and and seeing the response to
to the episode we did that the Lord of
the Rings not only the joy it's brought
people but also to raise $130,000 for no
Kid Hungry at a time when they
desperately needed that's what's keeping
me going
it's what's keeping me upright so happy
to do everything I can who's next the
Ghostbusters
are you serious I'm serious but I'm
doing with my emotion naturally to be a
very like random thing to lie to you
about that you can 5 truck easily online
and we need to see them right now too
because the movie got pushed back so
that's such a spare
Joe he's almost as smart as Artemis
everybody
Artemis is this Boy Wonder though you
know so is such a gifted young kid what
what were you really good at as a kid um
I was really good at imaginative play I
I used to have these GI Joes action
figures and I mean I've must have
sounded like a psychopath because you I
would I would immerse myself in this
world and bring these characters side
and what's so funny is this now I see my
own girls doing that imaginative plan
and it's so it's so amazing to see to
the point that I actually believe in
fairies now because they have this whole
like fairy world that is in their room
that is so real to them and they talked
to me about the fairies come at night
and visit and sometimes leave notes and
and so it's made me believe in fairies I
kind of love that I really do love that
I was one of those kids too we got about
I was an only child so I didn't have
anybody to play with so I had to like
make it all up and figure it all out my
son I'm one of three so it was a
different experience but they all do
than me because you were the youngest
you had that's exactly right so we got
Father's Day coming up is there anything
you like have been hinting dropping
little hints or what is the perfect was
the perfect Father's Day look likely
perfect Father's Day looks like the end
of 2020 it's like if someone could wrap
that up in a bow and just deliver me to
December 31st be an amazing Father's Day
gift I would love it how do you love it
know right now I'm not you know
I'm not really like my mind is so
rushing with so many emotions right now
that I haven't even thought about like
what I think what I could have that's
like going to distract me or you know
probably a charitable contribution is
like the most driver get right now
that's what my wife decided and my kids
decided to get me for Father's goal you
know and you mentioned like everything
is going on how your heads spinning I
actually have to say thank you for
making me laugh today because I've been
doing so much crying and sign and like
you know just worrying over the last few
days so I'm I wonder where your heart is
and how your heart is in the current
climate network my heart pokes I'm I'm
in pain I mean I'm in pain because I
thought we were past this and I'm angry
and I'm disturbed and I'm pissed I'm
just pissed I'm trying to use it as a
teaching moment trying to use it as a
learning moment trying to listen and do
what I can to raise two kids who can
deliver a better future then we've
managed to up until now and and it's
hard it's hard to it's hard to sort of
have to be as blunt as we have to be
right now with our kids but I'm also
very hopeful because I'm having a
discussion with a nine and six year old
about social justice with men that's
important and and and maybe this moment
can be a real sort of a moment a
movement that will change the future for
a lot of people can I ask you because I
know what those conversations are like
in black households because my parents
had them with me and I've had to have
them with my no God kids and cousins and
whatnot but what's that conversation
that a white parent has with their child
how do you approach this type of
conversation um from the perspective of
the experience from the externally the
perspective of what we don't know from
the perspective of how much ignorance
there is in the world so yesterday we or
two days ago rather we
Ava down my oldest and talked to her
specifically about George Floyd and and
and talked to her about the idea that
there is police brutality and obviously
you know her experiences are very
different because of the color of her
skin and we did it in a delicate away as
we could and and using a lot of the
touchstones that experts are sort of
talking about using but her response
really heartened me because she got
really angry and she said I don't
understand why anyone would be treated
differently based on the color of their
skin so it it makes me feel like there's
hope and it makes me feel like there's a
chance of change of real change because
she and her friends are now talking
about it I see the school talking about
it I see I see interactions that I
haven't necessarily seen before in real
time and I am fortunate enough to come
from a family who had very difficult
conversations with me when when I was
six years old my grandparents told me
about their experiences which are bowed
to the Holocaust and and and what
discrimination can can look like and and
how dark it can get and how you know how
many loved ones they had to say goodbye
to because they made the simple mistake
of being Jewish so I really I really am
doing my best to educate to inform and
again to learn to learn because I think
there's so much that that all of us have
to learn right now well just in your
daughter's response that should also
show you that you and your wife are
doing a pretty darn good job so I
appreciate that we've screwed them up in
so many of it one thing right
I appreciate you Josh all the time you
know you guys be well be safe and let's
see what you got next week what we gonna
do next week you want to go to space
like I just take a nap from the world I
just like I want to be written in Winkle
and wake up
[Music]